here with reaction the host of michelle
malkin investigates michelle malkin how
are you how are you doing John I'm happy
the president drew a line in the sand
and also put the world on notice that
he's not going to hold the world hostage
fire missiles over our allies threatened
Guam and threatened South Korea without
major repercussions in this case to me
that strength to the left that's
weakness yeah that's right
and the themes that were hammered by
President Trump of sovereignty Security
and Prosperity are somehow perceived in
the warped minds of all of these liberal
commentators gnashing their teeth as
quote-unquote dark and dangerous while
they ignore all of the dark and
dangerous evil that is looming and Iran
and North Korea and Venezuela president
Trump's message on Venezuela was
extremely strong and you never hear
those leftists on those other channels
ever talk about the repression and the
consequences of socialism on those
people in the dark and dangerous
influence of that what are they used to
why do they want out of a so-called
commander-in-chief they want Hillary
Clinton their Miss pay-for-play foreign
policy miss crony socialism herself to
be doing the same usual litany of
genuflection capitulation and and then
rinse and then repeat with toothless
sanctions that the only thing they ever
waive as their threat against these big
existential threats to America and the
world that that to me says it all I mean
if he marries and this is the same thing
with Iran where we are with North Korea
today we will be with Iran in probably a
few short years and that is this if you
take radicalism radical mullahs in Iran
you take this lunatic rocket man in
North Korea you marry him to weapons of
mass destruction and they can reach the
continental United States and we
depleted our strategic defense during
the Obama years we don't have a lot of
good options here now Newt Gingrich was
talking about kinetic answers last night
we could wipe out all their power it
would be the equivalent I assume of a
magnetic pulse in the United States very
damning not an option we want to use but
the other option is taking out their
nuclear sites and nuclear fallout and
whatever he may do while we're doing
that to South Korea or Japan or Guam not
good not good options not good options
and as you laid out so clearly in your
handy history which we all need these
history lessons every night Sean
it these are raw deals that were left on
the table for President Trump to have to
contend with and it was all of those
years of capitulating to the malach
recei allowing them to acquire all of
the stages weaponry and technology that
that now we have to deal with and yet
defending ourselves is somehow the real
threat do you see now the the meme
that's being planted on social media is
that Trump somehow is the one that is
threatening the lives of 25 million
people he's trying to save the lives of
every peaceful person on this planet one
last thing I saw your tweet we've been
friends for so many years I'm frustrated
with the Republicans because there's a
hundred in the house there's the seven
people that voted for full repeal in
2015 against it in 2017 so our options
are limited by people that never had any
intention of keeping their word we're
friends
you have had to deal with serious health
issues with your daughter and you tweet
it out about Jimmy Kimmel and I don't
like to get involved in kids I'm not
saying this is perfect but for the
Americans that only have one choice and
all those counties in America for the
Americans that have seen $8,000
increases in premiums when the President
does administration administrative
actions and governors I think you get
twice the bang for the buck than
anything from the federal government
it's not quite federalism but it's
certainly better than Obama care it's
not the best option but I want to see
that I am NOT endorsing it until I read
it but it's certainly a start to let
States handle it what do you think is
somebody that has had to deal with the
health care system on such a deep and
profound level yeah let me say a couple
things Shaun and thanks for asking I
completely we are on the same
in so many ways with our frustration at
the GOP establishment and how they have
failed to deliver on their core campaign
promises they scooped up they vacuumed
up so much of the hard-earned money of
the rank-and-file promising to do a
straight repeal to do the thing that
they did that they had Obama veto and
that is not what they offered so yes we
have to contend with something that is
less than perfect and as long as we've
we have people who are honest to say no
this isn't the repeal that we promised
you but it's the best that you're going
to get ultimately I think what this is
going to do is yes we get the repeal of
the individual and employer mandates
however you still have the entire
regulatory and subsidies structure
that's causing so many of the problems
that families across this nation have
had to suffer because next week
according to my sources administrative
Lee he's got to make it easier for coops
my buddy Josh Humber Atlas MD in in
Wichita who I've been interviewing for
years and it opens up the possibility of
health savings accounts to ideas we
believe in and the Republicans should
have been pushing no doubt I will say
this as a mother of a chronically ill
child who has had to deal with the
system who has had three individual
health plans canceled as a direct result
of the burden of Obamacare I will say
this I know that there are many
Republicans who are trying to do what
they said that they were going to do and
I support each and every one of them I
also know that you've got people in
Hollywood like Jimmy Kimmel who are
going to demonize every last person who
believes in a free-market alternative to
health care and what I have to say to
Jimmy Kimmel and celebrities like him is
how dare you tell us just because we
have a different point of view in a
different perspective on what the best
delivery mechanism is for health care
that we have no compassion that we're
the cruel ones that were heartless I'm
sick of that I know there are millions
of families like mine that feel the same
way listen you have a sick child and you
lose your health care three times that
is that is unforgivable and that's for
everybody but there are good options
I've been interviewing these people with
great ideas for years and we'll talk
more about it in the days and weeks to
come Michelle all the best to you and
your family